in the video on e 2 reactions I showed
you how a strong base and all this
happens simultaneously a strong base can
nab a hydrogen off of this carbon right
here it's just nabbing the proton itself
it's not grabbing the hydrogen and the
electron and then that electron goes to
this carbon right over there and then
that allows that carbon to give away the
electron that was forming a bond with
the chlorine to go with the chlorine
this all happens at once the chloride
got eliminated now one thing that might
pop out in your brain is why did I pick
this hydrogen why did I pick the
hydrogen right over here why couldn't I
have picked why couldn't I have picked
that hydrogen over there and I'm going
to introduce you a little bit of
terminology and then I'll introduce you
to a rule and then I'll tell you a
little bit about why people think this
rule works so in general the carbon that
has the functional group on it that's
the alpha carbon so let me label it this
carbon right here is the alpha carbon
and then in order to have an e2 reaction
in this case when we did the video on e
2 reactions but actually the rule will
hold as well for e 1 reactions but in
order to have the e2 reaction the
hydrogen has to get swiped off of a beta
carbon and a beta carbon is just a
carbon that's one away from the Alpha
carbon so this is a beta carbon and this
is also a beta carbon and so it's
completely reasonable one would think
that well it could swipe it from there
or it could swipe it from there and
let's think about this reaction let's
just draw it out so you could visualize
it a little bit better so here we swiped
it from this beta carbon let me redraw
the reaction where we're swiping it from
the other the other beta carbon so on I
want both reactions on the screen at the
same time so let me draw let me draw our
methoxide so we have our oxygen bonded
to a ch3 to a methyl group the oxygen
has 7 valence electrons 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
I'll do the seventh one the one that
will be the one that will bond with the
hydrogen I'll do it
Green and instead of attacking that
hydrogen or taking that proton I should
say because it's not taking the electron
with it it does it to this one so it
what it does is it takes this proton or
it bonds with that hydrogen proton and
then the hydrogen protons or that
hydrogen's electron can then be taken by
this molecule so then it goes to the
alpha carbon to form a double bond
between this beta carbon and the alpha
carbon and so now this alpha carbon got
that electron doesn't need the electron
it has it doesn't need the electron
that's bonded with the chloro group
anymore and so that goes to the chlorine
to form chloride it was already chlorine
was already way more electronegative it
was already hogging it now it gets to go
there and now when all is said and done
our products look like this we still
have so we still have the methanol just
like we had in the original reaction
because this grabbed this hydrogen let
me draw it so you have your o ch3 and
let me draw all of this so you have that
pair right over there you have this pair
right over here and then you have this
purple electron and now it's bonded with
this green electron which is ah now on
the hydrogen so it is now bonded with
this green electron that has been given
to the hydrogen oh and not to make sure
we don't forget it with this oxygen over
here it's seven valence electrons so it
had a negative charge neutral oxygen
would have six so this had a negative
charge but now that it gave its electron
to this hydrogen it now has a neutral
charge and is now methanol exactly what
we saw in when we first learned about II
1 reactions we also know that the claw
the chloro group it took that electron
it's now a chloride anion so let me draw
that and that's exactly the same as what
we won in the first video on e 1
reactions so it's now a chloride anion
it has grabbed this orange electron it
has grabbed the orange electron let me
do it in orange it has grabbed this
orange electron so it now has a negative
charge you can imagine that the negative
charge
has been transferred from the methoxide
to the chloride anion and now what's
different this time is that the double
bond is now between the 1 and the 2
carbon and not between the 2 and the 3
carbons so now it's going to look like
this so now the result this product if
the reaction went this way would look
like this we have this carbon right here
it is bonded to two hydrogen's it is
bonded to two hydrogen's now it has a
double bond with this carbon it has a
double bond and I'll do the second bond
I'll do the pi bond of the double bond
in purple right over there I'll assume
that that's the PI bond that's the new
double bond formed and now this carbon
this carbon let me do which was the
alpha carbon is right over here this was
the alpha carbon it's bonded to one
hydrogen and then let me draw everything
else so then you have a carbon carbon
this guy is bonded to three hydrogen's I
could have just written a ch3 if I
wanted this guy is bonded to two
hydrogen's and we're done and so instead
of as we saw in the first video on e 2
reactions instead of forming butte 2 een
we now have it still one two three four
carbons so still butte but the double
bond is on the one carbon right we'd
start 1 2 3 4 so we could call this
butte 1e nor 1 butene at either way so
let's call this beaut beaut 1 een so the
question is which is more likely to
happen do both happen does you know or
does one happen disproportionately and
the answer is is that yes what happens
disproportionately this one this is the
dominant product if you were to perform
this reaction this is what and you were
analyzed in your beaker wherever you're
performing the reaction what you see
most of the majority product the great
majority is going to be the Butte to
lean not the Butte 1e maybe you see very
very little of this and the question is
why or how would you even be able to
determine that or how could you have
predicted that and to predict it there's
something called site sells site says
rule and I'm sure I'm mispronouncing it
but let me write it down so site sells
Zaitsev Zaitsev
rule and it's kind of analogous to
markovnikov's rule but for elimination
reactions if you think about the
addition reactions that we did many
videos ago are the opposite of the
elimination reactions the addition
reactions we're adding the chloro group
and the elimination we're taking it off
and so the site subs rule is kind of
analogous to markovnikov's rule now
first I'll just tell you the rule then
we can think a little bit about why it
works and you know the jury is not out
on this people are they think they know
why it works but they're not 100% sure
so Zhai steps rule says the carbon that
is going to lose the hydrogen is the one
that has fewer hydrogen's so let me
write it down over here carbon carbon
more likely more likely to lose hydrogen
is I should say the hydrogen proton
because it keeps the electrons still is
the one with fewer fewer hydrogen's
fewer hydrogen's so if you were to look
at this reaction right here we have our
alpha carbon either this beta carbon or
this beta carbon could lose its hydrogen
this one has three hydrogen's on it this
one only has two so zayats halves rule
tells us that this that this is the
hydrogen or actually the proton that is
more likely to be reacted with the base
you could almost view this it is the
more acidic proton it is it is is a
lower hanging fruit for this strong base
to capture now a more interesting
question that's a pretty easy rule to
follow and if they both have the same
number then you'd see equal products
depending in on on which side it gets
now the question is the question is is
why is this happening and here something
called hyperconjugation comes into
effect hyperconjugation I'm not going to
go into details in it into the quantum
mechanics of it hyper hyper conjugation
and hyper conjugation is the notion is
the notion that the fact so we said that
the one with the fewer hydrogen's is the
one that's less likely to lose or the
one that few with fewer hydrogen's is
the one more likely to lose the hydrogen
proton but the
one with fewer hydrogen's is also bonded
to more carbons this guy is bonded to
one carbon this outside of the alpha
carbon is actually bonded to the Alpha
and this carbon this guy right here is
only bonded to the Alpha carbon and
hyperconjugation is the notion is the
notion that not the beta carbon but the
carbons one over from that help
stabilize the double bond that
eventually forms I almost think of it
you have you know you have more
electrons over here because carbon
carbons have more electrons to offer
than hydrogen's so you kind of have at
the end of the day this this guy is more
likely able to donate electrons to form
on from the right-hand side to make a
double bond then from the left-hand side
I won't go to the detail of
hyperconjugation but it's all based on
the notion that the more stable double
bond will be formed if we have other
carbons near the double bond and another
way to think about it is to look at the
products so we saw or Zaitsev rule tells
us that butte two een is a more likely
product than butte 1 een and if you look
at butte 1 een if you look at butte
wanting we could rewrite it like this we
could rewrite it like this we could draw
the we could draw the double bond like
this this carbon is what was this carbon
is what was the alpha carbon we could
draw a carbon right here and then it is
bonded to a hydrogen it's bonded to this
hydrogen and then it's bonded to just a
chain of it's just a chain of carbons
and we'll just draw we'll just write our
that and then this guy is just bonded to
two hydrogen's this guy is bonded to two
hydrogen's so this is butte this is well
this isn't necessary Bude wanting I just
put an R here but this is how it could
be represented now the butte to wean the
butte to wean if we wanted to draw it
like this would look like this if we
wanted to call we could call this right
here we could call this our prime it's
just a chain of carbons and then we
could call this and then we could call
this our prime prime it's another it's
it's not even a chain it's just one
carbon but if we call it that then the
butte to e let me draw it down here
where i have more real estate the two in
would look like this you have your
carbon-carbon double bond carbon carbon
double bond
the left hand carbon is bonded to a
hydrogen that hydrogen right there and
to our prime and to our prime and the
right hand carbon is bonded to a
hydrogen and our prime prime so it's
bonded to a hydrogen and our prime prime
all I did here let me see if I can fit
it all on the same screen as I just
redrew this and I just abstracted away
the chain as it goes away from the
double bond and I did that so that we
can look at it this way we can just have
the double bond kind of as our focus of
attention and think about what's going
on around it over here for the beaut 1e
and we say we already said this is the
lesser product so this is the greater
product this is the greater or the
dominant product and the lesser product
we only have if we go off of the double
pair double bond we only have one we
only have one alkyl group right there
that are right here over here we have
two and we say that this is more
substituted and when we say substitute
it you're imagining that you're
substituting hydrogen's with carbon
chains with alkyl groups so this one
right here is more more substituted and
hyperconjugation so the idea would have
it is that these these carbon chains
that are near the double bond help
stabilize it they're able to kind of sum
of their Sigma Sigma electrons and Sigma
orbitals are there to somehow to somehow
help stabilize the PI orbitals and now
this is getting into quantum mechanics
and all of that so it's a little bit and
it's you know the world is 100% clear
whether that's definitely the mechanism
although people have run the experiment
and they know that the more substituted
the more substituted product is what
you're going to see more of as opposed
to the less substituted and then that
all comes from sight cells rule so
hopefully you at least get Sciences rule
the hyper conjugation that's kind of a
deeper concept and it's you know the
jury is not even out on it that's a
belief of why site saves rule works but
the rule itself is pretty
straightforward if you're trying to pick
between two beta carbons the one that's
going to lose the hydrogen is the one
that already has fewer hydrogen's or the
one that's bonded to more
carbons and this is true I drew it we
did everything we focused on right now
was in an e2 reaction but it would it's
just as true in an e1 reaction